Hi guys and welcome to video 19, Portfolio
Correlation. As I said in the previous
video, portfolio volatility and
correlation are heavily linked and so
there is going to be some overlap between
what was taught in the previous video and
this one, but I do think it will be useful
to kind of reinforce some of the concepts
to get a more in-depth understanding about
correlation as a whole.
So as you can see in a break of tradition
here, I'm going to start with a few
PowerPoint slides in this video which will
help me introduce the concept of
correlation to you guys more broadly and
then we're going to take that knowledge
from the presentation and move over to a
spreadsheet model later which is just
going to kind of build on what we've
covered in the previous video.
With that being said, let me formalise
some of the questions I'm hoping will be
answered for you in this video.
So we're going to cover what correlation
is and how it's useful to traders and
portfolio managers.
We're going to look at why correlation is
important to consider when constructing
portfolios.
How traders and portfolio managers analyse
and monitor correlations within portfolios
by utilising tools like Excel.
How correlation helps traders and
portfolio managers make decisions to
enable better performance.
And also what are some of the common
pitfalls and downsides in correlation
analysis.
Before we get into the weeds of
correlation analysis and building on the
portfolio volatility model we looked at in
the last video, you need to first
understand what correlation actually is.
And correlation is basically just a
statistical measure that tries to quantify
the extent to which two variables
fluctuate together.
Or put simply, it tries to identify how
the two variables are related in a linear
fashion.
There are various measures of correlation,
but the most common is called the Pearson
coefficient of correlation.
And when I talk about correlation in this
video or in the course in general, this is
really the statistical measure that I'm
referring to.
The Pearson coefficient of correlation is
a pairwise correlation value that measures
the linear relationship between two
variables.
And I've got the formula up here.
And that isn't something you need to worry
about remembering, but what is useful is
just to have a general understanding of
how that formula works.
Given that you're going to be calculating
and using correlation figures in the
spreadsheets that we're looking at and
providing to you to help monitor and
manage your own portfolios.
So one of the major misunderstandings of
correlation is that people think that if
the two variables that they're looking at
both have positive changes in their data,
it means that the relationship or
correlation between them must also be
positive.
And unfortunately, that's the incorrect
assumption to make.
And in actual fact, what happens is that
for every observation of both the X and Y
variables that you're looking at, they're
converted and normalized to values that
represent their distances from the mean.
Not dissimilar, actually, to the
methodology that we looked at in the
previous video with the standard deviation
calculation.
Anyway, those values are then compared to
each other to compute an average
relationship over the entire data set.
And that number can then be interpreted to
answer whether the variables are
positively or negatively related and also
how strong that relationship is.
Speaking of the possible outputs of the
correlation equation, another thing you
ought to know is that correlation can take
any value between 1 and minus 1 or 100%
and minus 100%.
A value of 1 or 100% represents a
perfectly positive linear relationship
between two variables and a value of minus
1, which is the same as minus 100%, is a
perfectly negative linear relationship.
A correlation of 0 suggests that the
variables that you're looking at are
perfectly uncorrelated and there is no
linear relationship between them.
However, that doesn't mean that the
variables are independent from each other
because they could, of course, still have
a relationship with each other that isn't
defined in a linear fashion.
So let's have a look at some examples of
what various levels of correlation look
like in the form of scatterplot charts.
Now, if you don't really understand what
scatterplot charts are, you don't need to
worry about that too much at the moment.
You'll soon figure it out from the next
slide and then you can obviously sort of
rewind back to this slide if needed.
Essentially though, all I'm trying to
point out here at this stage is that if
there is an upward sloping relationship,
so from bottom left to top right, between
the two variables, then that represents a
positive correlation.
And a downward sloping relationship
represents a negative correlation.
The dispersion of the plots represent the
strength of the relationship.
And you can see in the top row here, the
more dispersed the data points are, the
closer to zero the correlation value
becomes.
And the gradient or the slope of the data
points is actually irrelevant to the
strength of relationships.
The strength of relationships is defined
by the dispersion, as I said, not the
gradient of the slope.
And you can see that in the bottom line of
plots as well.
Okay, let's look at a real example now
using real data that everyone's familiar
with so that you can understand, or at
least everyone sort of understands.
What we're looking at here is a
scatterplot showing the relationship
between major league baseball players'
height and weight.
Anecdotally, of course, we would expect
weight and height to have a positive
relationship,
which means taller people tend to be
heavier and vice versa.
In this chart, height is measured in
inches for each player.
And that's plotted on the x-axis, which is
the horizontal axis.
And weight is measured in pounds for each
player.
And that's plotted on the y-axis, which is
the vertical axis.
Each dot on the chart is a data point that
has a value for both height and weight.
And of course, those dots represent the
major league baseball players from this
sample of data.
So what can we analyze from this chart?
Well, first off, we can see the heaviest
player weighs in around 290 pounds and the
lightest players weigh around 150 pounds.
The tallest player measures 83 inches,
whilst the shortest players are around 67
inches.
And you can see that a line of best fit
has been drawn through all of these data
points.
And formally, this line is calculated by
minimizing the distances between all of
the data points in the chart.
But you can just think of this really as
the sort of average relationship between
the variables height and weight.
The majority of the data points that we
can see are clustered in the middle of the
chart,
which makes perfect sense because most
people obviously have a fairly average
height and weight by definition.
And if you know anything about normal
distributions, then that's going to make
perfect sense to you.
So anyway, when you calculate the
correlation for this data, it comes out as
0.53,
which is quite a strong positive linear
relationship.
And you can see that reflected in the
chart here.
As players height sort of deviates from
the mean, so does their weight in the same
direction typically.
So we have this upward sloping
relationship with not too much dispersion,
hence quite a strong correlation value of
0.53.
So now you have an understanding of what
correlation is.
Here's a few ways that correlation
analysis can be useful to traders and
portfolio managers in general.
The first one is intermarket analysis.
OK, that's monitoring market and economic
relationships to sort of understand the
current picture
and where we might be headed as well as
where opportunities potentially exist.
That's a little bit like the sort of stuff
that we cover in the macro sections of
this video series.
It's also useful for hedging.
OK, calculating relationships between
assets can be sort of helpful to reduce or
hedge exposure in various ways.
So it basically allows traders to target
more specific features in their returns
profile.
In the next video, I'm going to talk to
you about beta, which is actually sort of
an extension really of correlation
and a measure which is used a lot by
professional traders to hedge exposure in
their portfolios.
The third and final useful sort of way to
use correlation is through diversification
and risk in the portfolio.
And really, that's the most important use
of correlation analysis.
And that's our focus as traders and
portfolio managers.
And I've talked about this in the previous
video and we're going to carry on with
that here.
Now, you guys have seen this chart already
and I talked through the principles behind
it in the previous video.
It is important though, so I'm going to go
through things briefly again here.
This chart really sums up why correlation
between positions in your portfolio is so
important to consider.
It basically shows us the benefits of
diversification or really what I like to
call efficient diversification.
For those of you that don't know what
diversification really means, it's
basically the process of pulling assets
together
that have diverse drivers or factors that
affect their values so that the risk of
the whole portfolio is reduced.
And as a reminder, in this chart, what
we're looking at are various portfolios
where each colored line represents a
different portfolio.
And in each of these portfolios, the
constituent assets are assumed to have
equal capital weightings,
equal volatility values and equal pairwise
correlations to all of the other positions
in the portfolio.
Obviously, in reality, these assumptions
are far fetched, but they allow us to
understand the theory of portfolio
diversification much more easily.
What I'm really trying to show in this
chart is that there are two core factors
that affect an equally weighted
portfolio's volatility, as you know.
The volatility of the assets in the
portfolio and the correlations between
those assets.
Now, knowing that, the next question we
should have is, well, how much do each of
these factors have an effect?
And the answer is that it depends on the
size of the portfolio.
What we can see in this chart is that as
assets are added to the portfolios, as
long as the correlation of those positions
is less than one,
one, the risk or volatility of the
portfolio falls quite significantly.
The lower the correlation, the more
efficient the diversification process
becomes and the faster the risk decreases.
So, for example, the blue and orange
portfolios you can see both have exactly
the same asset volatility assumptions.
And so, when there's only one asset in the
portfolio, the volatility of the portfolio
is the same, 35% on an annualized basis.
However, as assets are added to those
portfolios, the volatility of the orange
portfolio reduces at a much faster rate
because the correlation values assumed
between the constituents in that portfolio
are set to 0.2 as opposed to 0.45 in the
blue portfolio.
Now, let's consider that question that I
mentioned previously again.
When portfolios contain just a very small
number of assets, for example, one or two,
then the volatilities of the individual
assets are quite important to overall
portfolio volatility.
However, in any reasonably sized
portfolio, it's the correlation values
that matter much, much more.
And we did see this in the previous video
when I was looking at the variance
covariance matrix and kind of running
through examples there.
But you can also see it in this chart
here.
So, on that point, you might be asking
next whether it's a good idea to
continually add positions that have
relatively low correlations to the
portfolio to keep reducing risk further
and further.
And as I've also said previously, the
simple answer to that is a resounding no.
And that is for two main reasons.
One of the primary measures of good
trading is achieving what's called good
risk adjusted returns, meaning your
portfolio generates good returns for
relatively little risk over time.
And that can be measured in a few ways.
We've already touched on the Sharpe ratio,
and we're going to look at that amongst
some other performance metrics as well
later in the series.
If you take a look at the chart here,
you'll see that there comes a point for
every portfolio where adding new positions
doesn't really affect the overall
portfolio volatility.
The lower the correlations are of the new
positions, the more risk is reduced.
But that being said, the marginal
reduction in risk always diminishes with
every new position.
And there comes a point usually between
sort of eight to 12 positions, sometimes a
bit more, where there becomes very little
benefit in terms of reduced portfolio
volatility.
Bearing that in mind, let's think about
the return side of our risk adjusted
returns metrics.
When building a portfolio, it's not
unreasonable to think that the number of
high quality trade ideas anyone can come
up with is finite.
High quality, high conviction ideas are
the positions that generate the most
returns in your portfolios.
And when you add more and more positions
to the portfolio, it's likely that the
quality of those ideas will diminish.
So not only does adding more and more
positions to the portfolio for the sake of
diversification have diminishing benefits
in terms of risk reduction, it also
reduces your expected returns.
This process is what's known as over
diversification and it can dramatically
decrease your portfolio performance.
Typically, depending on the amount of
capital you have to trade, you're likely
going to be looking at having around eight
to 12 positions on any one time in the
portfolio.
As I said in the previous video, that
might increase a little bit depending on
the sort of total capital you have
available and obviously the sort of market
situation and so on.
To summarize this slide, we can see how
important efficient diversification and
correlation is in our portfolios.
However, we do need to be cognizant of
taking things too far.
Always make sure that in your sort of
prospective portfolios, positions are
driven primarily by fundamental factors.
And only then should you think about
correlation and portfolio construction.
And we'll talk more on that shortly.
Okay, before going on to some practical
spreadsheet stuff, I want to go through a
few pitfalls of correlation analysis.
And this isn't to put you off by any
means, but it is there to give you a
deeper understanding of how correlation
works and what you might need to consider
or look out for if you're using
correlation values in your own analysis or
portfolio.
The first one we've already covered, over
diversification can lead to lower returns,
both in sort of absolute and risk adjusted
terms.
The second point I want to make is that
correlation is not the same as causation.
What I mean by that is just because there
might be a linear relationship between two
variables, however strong, it doesn't mean
that there is a cause and effect
relationship between them.
A change in one might not cause a change
in the other.
If there isn't a cause and effect
relationship, then without understanding
the cause factor for a correlation, then
there is going to be uncertainty that the
correlation will stay constant.
If we think about the previous video and
our own portfolios, that obviously has
implications for using assumptions of
covariance or correlations in our model.
We have to appreciate that these variables
are all subject to change, so that doesn't
make them redundant, it just means we're
trying to work with the data that we have
available, but we need to be aware that
that data isn't perfect.
Ideally, when it comes to building
portfolios, it would be optimal to build
them with positions that have very
different fundamental drivers so that we
can try and assure that correlations
remain low going forward.
However, it's impossible to know all of
the factors that affect assets, and if you
thought you could get close, then they
would probably change over time anyway.
A classic example of how correlations can
change over time is seen in the
relationship between US stocks and bonds.
This chart here shows the rolling
five-year correlation between 10-year
treasury prices and the S&P 500, which you
can see pre-1998 was quite strongly
positive, but in the next five years
turned negative and has stayed that way
ever since.
I'm not going to go into details as to why
I think that's happened, because it's
besides the point.
But what's noteworthy is that it has
happened, and it's a great example of how
correlations can break down or even
invert.
Next one, this might sound silly to you
guys, but correlation really is just a
number.
It captures the linear relationship
between two variables in a very specific
way and based on the data in the sample
that it's calculated from.
It's very easy to misinterpret, and if you
really want to understand the relationship
between data, then you're going to have to
do more than just look at some descriptive
statistics and correlations.
And Anscombe's Quartet is a classic
example of this.
So Anscombe's Quartet consists of four
different data sets, all with the same
core descriptive characteristics.
They have the same average, variance,
correlations, regression equations, and so
on, which might make you think that these
data sets are clearly very, very similar.
However, in this case, you'd be wrong in
that assumption.
And you can see here the differences in
the data sets are massive.
The point here is that correlation, like
any other statistic, is just a number, and
you need to understand when it's useful
and when it isn't.
And often to do that, you'll have to use
other investigative methods to really
understand the data itself.
I mentioned that here really for two
reasons.
Firstly, to warn you of the limitations of
certain statistics when taken in and of
themselves.
And secondly, to encourage you to go a
little bit further in your own work and
analysis, because that's going to give you
more confidence in the outcomes that you
then reach.
Another very common mistake, and one I
mentioned earlier in the video, is
assuming that if two data sets are
trending in the same direction, then their
correlation must be positive and vice
versa.
If you remember back to the equation, it's
calculated based on the relative
difference in each observation from the
mean of the data set for each variable.
But the means of each data set themselves
could be very different.
So for example, if the mean return of
asset X is minus 1% and the mean return of
asset Y is plus 1% over all observations.
But for every sort of individual
observation, when asset X returns above
the mean above minus 1% and asset Y
returns above its mean above 1%, then
there will be a very strong positive
correlation.
This concept is probably more easily
illustrated through an example.
And here I've got a chart showing the
price of a real estate ETF, IYR is the
ticker, versus an inverse real estate ETF,
REK, over the year 2020.
And as you would sort of predict, the
correlation of these instruments is almost
perfectly negative, it's minus 0.99.
However, if you take the trend in price of
both of those funds over that year, they
actually both go down.
Meaning, if you bought both at the start
of the year 2020, expecting a perfect
hedge, you would have actually lost money
on both sides of the trade, despite a near
perfect negative correlation.
The lesson here is, remember that
correlation works by comparing data points
to the means of the sort of X and Y
variables.
So the means of the variables themselves
can be very different and still yield
perfect correlations.
The final pitfall that I want to talk
about, which I mentioned briefly earlier
as well, is common to many statistics.
And that is that the calculation itself,
the correlation is dependent obviously on
the data set that's used.
And can of course vary for the same two
variables by looking at different samples.
So for example, using different sort of
time periods or frequencies of data.
We've seen what happens to the correlation
of bonds and stocks already.
But another very important situation to
look at is what happens in crises when
liquidity dries up in the market, for
example.
In this table below, I've calculated
correlations between the S&P 500 and
various other assets by first filtering
the days on which the VIX is at various
levels to act as a proxy for liquidity
levels.
And you can see that as the VIX increases,
correlations across assets, particularly
in equities, tends to one.
And this is actually a double whammy
effect on your portfolio volatility.
Not only do individual asset volatilities
increase, but also correlations magnify
this effect at the portfolio level.
Okay, guys, now we've gone through some
correlation theory and understand some
pitfalls of correlation values themselves.
We're well prepared to plow on and look at
how it can actually be useful to us.
And really, this is just going to build on
the spreadsheet stuff that we looked at in
the previous video.
So this spreadsheet is almost exactly the
same as the one that we looked at
previously with just a few extra bits
added on.
The main functionality that we're going to
look at is at the portfolio level in the
portfolio volatility practice sheet again.
And I've made a small addition to the
model here for you guys this time, which
incorporates a portfolio correlation table
at the bottom of the sheet.
I'm going to talk about how you can use
that as sort of you're going through the
process of building your own portfolios or
testing different scenarios.
And we'll go back and take a look at some
of the examples that we looked at in the
previous video as well to get to grips
with it all.
Other than that, the only major difference
in this sheet is that I'm going to use
this correlation function sheet to show
you how to calculate correlation values
yourselves for any variables that you can
get data for,
which may help you with your own analysis,
given some of the ideas and things that
we've been talking about in this video and
the last one.
It's just really a sort of really useful
tool to develop your understanding.
And we're going to go through a worked
example with a couple of stocks.
There is one more new sheet, which you'll
see here, which is the variance covariance
matrix sheet.
That's just a massive covariance matrix,
which I've built using all of the stocks
that I've listed on the summary page.
And I just want to make a quick reference
to that at some stage in the video to
illustrate a point.
We'll get to that.
But first of all, I want to begin with
showing you guys how to calculate
correlation in Excel in this correlation
function sheet.
Now, as you can see here, I've got some
weekly price data for WMS.
That ticker is advanced drainage systems
and OGS.
That's one gas.
This is exactly the same data that we have
in the asset prices sheet for these two
stocks.
And it goes back as far as mid 2015
historically.
And what we're going to do here is
calculate the correlation between these
two stocks using three different samples
of data.
Firstly, I'm going to compute the
correlation based on the entire six years
of price data that we have available here.
And then I'm going to calculate both the
one and two year rolling correlations and
plot them in a chart so that you can see
the difference.
It's all pretty simple stuff, really.
And it involves a very similar
methodology.
And once we've kind of been through it,
hopefully you guys will be comfortable
doing this sort of correlation analysis
and calculations yourselves.
So when we calculate correlations, we base
it on returns rather than prices.
And so to begin with, we need to calculate
all the weekly returns given our price
data.
And then we can move on to the correlation
function itself.
Now, as you guys know by now, calculating
returns is pretty easy.
And I'm just going to do that in columns D
and E quickly.
So we just take the current price divided
by the previous price minus one.
That's our formula.
And then we copy down that formula for
each stock in order to generate our series
of returns.
As always, when we do that, we'll be left
with errors at the beginning of the data
series since returns on a given date
require prices from the previous period.
And at the start of the series, there's no
previous periods to look up prices for.
So we just delete the contents of those
cells and our return series becomes one
period shorter than our price series.
So with returns computed, we can now look
at calculating correlation.
The function that we're going to use here
to calculate correlation in Excel is just
called CORAL.
So that's equals CORAL.
And if I type that in cell H1, you'll see
that within the function, there are two
parameters to assign.
So equals CORAL open brackets.
And we can see that there's two parameters
to assign basically array one and array
two.
And these are just your references to your
X and Y variable data sets.
So that's just going to be the returns for
WMS and OGS in this example.
It doesn't matter which data series you
enter first.
But here what I'm going to do is just
select all of our WMS returns data as the
first parameter.
And then enter a comma to move on to array
two and select all of the OGS returns
data.
We're selecting all of the data available
at this point because we want to calculate
the historic correlation over the entire
data set in this first example.
One thing to note here when using the
correlation function function in Excel is
that you must always use data series that
are aligned and have the same number of
data points.
Otherwise, it's not going to work.
So the arrays, the reference arrays for
both sort of parameters, both variables
need to be exactly the same length.
And if they're not the same length, it
won't work.
And then obviously for your own benefit,
you want to make sure that all of the
prices or whatever data that you're
looking at matches in each row as well for
the dates that you're considering.
So with that data entered, you can see the
correlation measures roughly 0.27 over the
whole data set.
Let's have a look now at rolling
correlations where we're going to use
firstly a rolling one year window to
compute correlations over using the same
data series that we've just referenced
previously as well.
So in column F, I'm going to head the
column one year role coral.
And in cell F2, we're going to use the
same correlation function equals coral.
But this time when selecting the two
return series, I'm going to make sure that
the arrays only account for the last year
of data.
So in this example, that means putting in
equals coral open brackets and we're going
to select from cells D2 to D54 for the
first array and cells E2 to E54 for the
second array.
The reason why we're going to row 54 is
because that then accounts for 52 weeks of
data and that is equivalent to one year.
So over the latest year of data, you can
see, and I say latest year of data because
we're looking firstly in the top row at
the most recent data that we have
available.
So over the latest year of data, you can
see the correlation has measured much less
than our sort of overall correlation for
the entire data set.
So the reading is 0.04 and that shows
already how much correlation can change
between two variables if we if we didn't
already kind of anticipate that that could
happen.
Let's take this a step further, though,
and create a time series of one year
rolling correlations.
All we need to do to do that is just copy
that correlation formula down to the end
of the series.
And because the cell references we used in
the arrays were dynamic, so not fixed,
they effectively calculate our rolling one
year correlation for the entire data set.
Now, if we scroll down to the bottom of
the data set, there is something that we
need to address and be careful of.
Firstly, you can see that there's a few
div zero errors at the end of the series.
And above these errors, there are some
correlation values, but those values are
only being calculated with much less data
than a year's data.
So, for example, if we double click into
cell F300, you'll see that it's
referencing a lot of blank cells because
there isn't a year of data available
before the 24th of September 2015 in this
data set.
So you have an option here. You can either
leave values like this in and just
understand that they're not using a full
year of data to calculate.
Or we can just delete all the correlation
cells that don't use a full one year
window that we're kind of looking for.
Now, I'm going to do the latter here. And
by the way, it goes without saying that
you should also delete the div zero cells
no matter what.
So all I'm going to do here is look at the
row with the earliest returns values in,
which is row 309 in this case.
And then minus 52 from that number because
there's 52 weeks in a year.
That gives us row 257. And so we know that
this is the last correlation calculation
cell that we want in this column.
And you can double click on that cell to
make sure that it's the final reference
row in it is row 309.
After establishing that, all we do is
select all of the calculation cells below
that one and clear the content by pressing
delete on the keyboard.
So we're going to do one more calculation
column now where we'll compute a two year
rolling correlation window rather than the
one year.
And I'm going to plot these then in a line
chart afterwards quickly to sort of show
you the difference.
OK, so in cell G1, I'll head the column
two year roll coral and in cell G2.
It's exactly the same formula as we've
been using previously, except the array
windows are going to be increased to
incorporate two years of data, which takes
us this time to row 106.
So with the formula entered, all we do is
copy it down again and then delete all the
correlation values in this column that
don't encompass a full two years of
returns data.
In this case, that means deleting the
contents of all cells from cell G206 and
below.
And note that when we do this, that
obviously the two year correlation series
that we've just created is shorter by a
year than the one year rolling series that
we created before.
OK, before I comment on any of these
numbers, let's finish up by plotting a
line chart of the two correlation series
that we've just created.
You guys already know how to do this by
now, so I'll just zip through this very
quickly.
I'm just going to select a blank cell in
the sheet somewhere, followed by
navigating to insert on the ribbon and
selecting a 2D line chart.
Next, I'm going to right click within the
chart area, go to select data series and
select the data that we want to plot.
In this chart, obviously, we're dealing
with different length data sets.
So I find the easiest way to handle that
is typically to reference data series and
dates down to the row of the longest data
series.
In this case, that's going to be the one
year correlation series.
That series ends in row 257.
And so when adding each series and their
respective dates, I'm just going to make
sure that the reference always finishes at
row 257.
So we have the data in the chart now, and
I'm just going to tidy it up quickly by
adding a legend and then moving the date
axis to the bottom of the chart.
And first of all, to add the legend, I'm
just going to select the chart and go to
chart design on the ribbon, followed by
add chart element, then choose legend and
choose top.
So put the legend at the top of the chart.
Then to move the date labels, I'm going to
double click on the date labels
themselves.
And in the panel on the right hand side
that appears within the axis options tab,
I'm going to click on labels at the bottom
and then change the label position to low.
All right.
So what can we see here?
Well, firstly, clearly correlations can
change quite a bit over time.
This is an example where the correlations
are particularly volatile, I think, but it
does go to show that when calculating or
relying on correlation values from the
past,
you do have to accept and understand that
they're not perfect and they could easily
change.
Secondly, you can see that there's quite
an obvious difference in the one and two
year rolling correlations.
Basically, the two year correlations are
less sensitive and less volatile than the
one year ones, which makes sense because
more data is being used to calculate them.
In a sense, you can look at this in the
same way that you might look at moving
averages or anything like that.
The smaller the calculation window, the
more sensitive the series and the quicker
that you'll pick up any changes in the
data or in the correlation in this
instance.
But equally, the more unstable it is and
arguably the less reliable it is in the
case of correlations because it doesn't
take advantage of as much data in the
computation.
A similar thing can be said for taking
snapshots of correlation values.
So, you know, the shorter or more and more
recent window of data you use, the more
timely it is and you might think that's a
better indication of correlation in the
future.
Or you may think using larger windows is
better because there's more data involved
in the calculation and quite often
correlations revert to their mean.
There is no right answer here in the
portfolio volatility model that I've
created in this sheet.
I've used all time covariances and
correlations and variances as estimates.
But you may find when you do more targeted
correlation analysis using the coral
function here that you prefer shorter
windows.
What I would say is that I don't think
it's sensible really to use anything less
than a year of data.
But really the data window you use for
calculating any statistics is up to you.
What I kind of wanted to point out here
mostly is that you will see variation
depending on the data window that you use.
And I wanted to quickly point out some of
the benefits and drawbacks of using kind
of longer and shorter timeframes to
calculate your statistics from.
So the point of going through this little
section was firstly to show you how you
can quickly and easily calculate
correlations yourselves in Excel for any
data sets that you've been using.
Just by using the correlation function
that we've looked at.
And I also wanted to build on that by
showing you how to create a time series of
correlation because that's going to
enhance your understanding of whatever two
variables it is that you're looking at in
your correlation analysis.
Clearly as well this exercise also
reinforced one of the pitfalls that I
mentioned about correlation analysis
earlier in that correlations are subject
to change.
That's not exactly a pitfall.
It's just something that we have to
understand and be aware of and accept
because although they can change using a
sample of historical data is still the
only simple way to estimate what
correlations might be in the future.
And it's those correlation values in the
form of sort of covariances that are then
fed into our portfolio volatility model in
this sheet.
So with that being said, let's head back
over to the portfolio volatility practice
sheet now where I'm going to run through
some scenarios again and this time
incorporate some correlation analysis
along the way.
Okay, as I said earlier, this sheet is
basically the same as the one that you saw
in the last video, apart from that it now
also contains this correlation table,
which we're going to be using in the
scenarios that follow.
So to make things easy, the portfolio
scenarios I'm going to go through here are
exactly the same as the ones that we
looked at in the previous video, except
this time we're going to be looking at the
correlation side of things specifically.
You'll see here, I already have our first
scenario set up, which is the 10 stock
portfolio that's long mega cap and large
cap positions, including our FAANG stocks.
As we saw previously, the annual
volatility for this portfolio is estimated
at 19.23% with an average annual asset
standard deviation estimation of 28.28%.
So let's now have a look at the
correlations in more detail for this
portfolio.
At the bottom of the sheet, I've got this
correlation matrix, which as far as user
input goes, works in a very similar
fashion to the way the variance covariance
matrix above works.
At the moment, this matrix is empty, but
all we need to do to conduct our analysis
is basically fill out the orange cells in
columns B and AB with tickers and values
that represent whether the position is a
long or a short.
Because there aren't tickers entered into
this correlation matrix matrix at the
moment, but we do have some in the
variance covariance table above, you can
see that there are some warning signs in
column A that basically show us a sort of
caution if there is any mismatch between
the tickers seen in the adjacent cells
compared to the tickers seen in the
representative cells in the matrix above.
So all we need to do to get started with
looking at correlations in the current
portfolio is enter the tickers we have in
the portfolio above into column B of the
correlation matrix and in the same order.
Now, you can obviously type these in
manually or if you want to do things a
little bit quicker, you can copy the
orange cells in the portfolio table above
and paste them as values as we sort of did
in the previous portfolio in the previous
video into the relevant cells as follows.
And you can see now that our matching
signals have turned to a green tick which
basically shows all of the tickers are in
the right order and match those seen in
the variance covariance matrix above.
Next, we need to define whether these
positions are long or shorts in column AB.
In the table above, this is sort of
defined implicitly really by the net
allocation that we've assigned. Positive
values are longs, negative values are
shorts.
In this table, we're not worried about
weightings, we only need to know whether
each position is a long or a short.
And this is done by selecting either a 1
or a minus 1 from the dropdown menus in
each cell in column AB.
Long positions should have a value of 1,
short positions should have a value of
minus 1.
And we're considering a long only
portfolio in this scenario, so clearly all
of the values here should be set to 1.
So with that done, you can now see the
correlation matrix is populated with
values.
Each of these values represent the
pairwise correlation for the assets seen
in the relevant row and column.
For example, the correlation between Apple
and Microsoft is estimated at 63.95% and
the correlation between Facebook and
Netflix is estimated to be 40.01%.
These correlations are calculated from the
full time series of returns that's been
computed in the asset return sheet.
So whatever time horizon that you've got
set in that sheet defines the estimates
for all of our variances, covariances and
correlations in this model.
The idea of this correlation matrix is
that you can quickly and easily see which
positions in the portfolio you expect to
be more or less correlated with each
other.
I've also tried to make an aggregate
analysis of each position a bit easier by
calculating average correlations at the
end of each row in column AC.
So for example, here we can see that
Microsoft has an average pairwise
correlation with all the other positions
in the portfolio of 53.34%.
Whilst Netflix has an average correlation
value of 34.5%.
Based on these correlation values, we can
see which assets have relatively high
correlations and which are more effective
diversifiers.
And all else being equal, you could argue
that the assets with the lowest average
correlations are the most important
portfolio components.
Now, of course, practically speaking,
there is so much more to consider, such
as, you know, idea quality and its
potential for returns, as well as, you
know, whether these correlation values are
actually reasonably estimated and
indicative of future relationships between
assets.
But nonetheless, it gives us a very solid
insight into which assets are likely to
have higher or lower correlations going
forward.
As well as those average correlations for
each position, I've also got a cell that
calculates the average pairwise
correlation across the whole portfolio,
which is cell AC.74.
Currently, that's reading 42.79% for this
portfolio.
This is somewhat analogous to the
correlation value we saw in the
diversification principles chart.
And so clearly, you know, the lower the
correlation, the better in terms of risk.
Again, there are more things to consider
here, such as the assumptions that all
assets are equally weighted for the
purposes of this correlation matrix.
And also, lower risk doesn't necessarily
mean a better portfolio.
Remember, it's it's more about the risk
adjusted returns of the portfolio.
So basically, this correlation matrix is
useful to us because we know how important
correlation is to the overall portfolio
volatility.
And this matrix allows us to understand
and identify where the most significant
relationships between positions in our
portfolio might lie.
And therefore, gives us an idea about
tweaking weightings and positions to
affect the overall portfolio volatility.
I'm going to stress this again, though.
Correlation analysis is important, but it
shouldn't supersede fundamentals in the
decision to enter trades or not.
So always remember that.
Let's look over our second scenario now,
though, which is our long, large and mid
cap portfolio.
I'm going to copy and paste the tickers
for that portfolio from the front summary
sheet here and paste them into both the
variance covariance matrix and the
correlation matrix inside our portfolio
volatility practice sheet.
Now for this scenario, I don't need to
change any orange cells in column AB since
the allocations that we're assuming for
the portfolio matrix are the same and the
positions are all longs as well.
So the correlation matrix doesn't need
updating in that column either.
So as we saw in the previous video, the
portfolio volatility and average position
volatility for this scenario is quite a
bit higher than the last one, reading
29.36% and 44.33% respectively.
However, when we look at the correlation
matrix, it's pretty clear that our average
correlations are lower than the previous
scenario, 38.52% versus 42.79%.
Now, these results are actually very
typical of the difference between mega cap
and mid cap portfolios.
Mid caps tend to have higher individual
volatilities, as we know, which means they
typically have greater expected returns.
But also they tend to have lower average
correlations to other stocks than mega
caps do, which makes them better, more
efficient portfolio diversifiers as well.
And when you think about this, that makes
a lot of sense because smaller companies
tend to have less diversified operations.
And so their revenues, earnings and
therefore stock prices are dictated by
factors that are less diluted and less
common to other stocks.
You can also see that the average
correlation values between each position
are lower.
So the maximum average correlation we see
here is 45.75% assigned to ticker LEN and
the minimum is 29.96% assigned to VTRS.
And by the way, these lower average
correlation values in this portfolio that
includes mid caps now aren't a fluke.
If you need a bit more confirmation about
that, you can have a look at the variance
covariance correlation matrix sheet,
where I've set up a table that calculates
the correlations between all of the stocks
listed in this spreadsheet.
And I've aggregated them to create average
correlations amongst mid caps compared to
large and mega caps.
And as you'd expect, mid caps tend to have
lower average correlations.
And in reality, if you were to include all
US listed stocks, not just the ones I have
here, the difference would be even
greater.
And the results I have here, therefore,
are kind of skewed in the favor of large
and mega caps anyway.
I've put a couple of notes about that in
the sheet here.
But basically it's because the sample size
for mid caps would actually be much, much
larger than how it's sort of represented
here in this sheet.
So the takeaway from this scenario is
again reinforcing the fact that mid caps
have multiple benefits when included in
our portfolios.
It's greater volatility in themselves,
which gives a scope for increased expected
returns, but also higher diversification
benefits as well.
Now, our third and final scenario is our
long short mid and large cap portfolio,
where we're long six stocks, the majority
being mid caps and short four stocks.
This portfolio, as I said in the previous
video, is much closer to the kind of
portfolio we'd expect ITPM traders to
build because it utilizes long and short
positions as well as mid cap stocks.
To make things easy and comparable, you'll
remember we actually kept the exact exact
same stocks for this portfolio as the last
one.
But all we did was sort of change the
allocations to include short positions.
If you remember, the top four tickers in
this portfolio, which are all large cap
stocks, are short positions.
And so in the volatility model, we need to
change the allocations to those four
positions to minus $10,000 instead of plus
$10,000.
Equally for the correlation model, those
four positions need to be assigned minus
one values in the column AB to make them
short rather than values of one.
As in the last video, when these inputs
are entered, we retrieve a portfolio
volatility value of 11.23% and maintain
the exact same average asset volatility
number of 44.33%.
That's because we're obviously using the
same stocks.
We're just changing the weightings to
include some shorts.
So let's have a look at the correlation
matrix now for this scenario.
And it's here where we can see a massive
difference in average correlations across
the board.
Overall, correlations have become much,
much closer to zero and some have turned
negative because of the inclusion of short
positions.
And that gives us an overall average
portfolio correlation of minus 4.69%.
And this is the main reason why we've seen
such a dramatic decrease in the portfolio
volatility estimate.
Including both long and short positions
has resulted in this sort of incredibly
efficient diversification through these
really low correlation estimates.
And all the while, we're still taking
advantage of high volatility individual
positions by including many mid caps.
So now we've been through those scenarios.
Let's go through a few examples using this
correlation model.
So let's say that we're currently holding
this portfolio, which by the way, isn't
something that you should be doing when
you view this course.
These trades are just examples only and
they're clearly not relevant to your own
kind of circumstance or probably the time
that you're actually watching this series
anyway.
And that goes for any kind of examples
that we look out throughout look at
throughout the series.
They are just examples.
You've always got to do your own work.
But anyway, for example, let's say we're
holding this portfolio and we have a watch
list running in the background with a
bunch of great fundamentally driven ideas.
At some point, the timing of one of our
ideas, let's say long temple Sealy, so TPX
looks good and we're thinking about
putting the position on.
Before doing so, though, we might want to
see how this trade fits in our current
portfolio structure.
And we can also model the effects of
including it on overall portfolio
volatility expectations.
And it would be nice to see how it
correlates to other positions in the
portfolio as well.
Assuming we have capital to spare, let's
model what would happen if we include this
position in the portfolio with an
allocation of $10,000.
To do that, we would just enter the ticker
TPX into both the volatility and
correlation models
and assign a capital allocation of $10,000
to the volatility matrix and a one value
to the correlation matrix in column AB.
If we then take a look at the results, we
can see that the overall portfolio
volatility estimate has increased by about
1.5%.
And as far as correlation values go,
nothing really sticks out.
TPX pairwise correlations are okay across
the board.
Nothing's particularly high, not enough to
cause a red flag anyway.
And the average correlation for that
position to the other positions is also
okay.
It's not the highest, it's not the lowest
and overall it has increased the average
correlation to minus 2.66%.
All pretty insignificant and that's a good
sign really.
When doing this, we just want to
understand how it sits, how the new
position that we're looking at, sits in
the portfolio
and make sure that there's no obviously
high correlations or increases in
portfolio volatility
that then might cause red flags and
warrant further investigation.
The majority of the time in your own
portfolios, this is going to be the case.
If both the fundamentals and technicals
for a prospective position look good, it's
generally going to be okay to put on,
but it is still worth modeling and
checking what's happening at the portfolio
level
to make sure that you're happy and there's
no sort of red flags being raised.
Now, if you guys are really doing your
work properly, you might be in a situation
where you actually have a high number of
quality ideas
ready to go at the same time whilst also
maintaining a reasonably full portfolio.
Now, if that's the case, you've got some
decisions to make.
Do you want to swap any positions out?
If not, do you have any capital spare to
add new ones?
If you can only add one out of, say, two
or three trades, how are you going to
choose?
Again, I'm always going to say that these
decisions should be driven primarily
by the fundamental strength of the idea
and your own conviction.
However, in the scenario where you might
be choosing between a couple of ideas
and everything about them seems equal in
terms of quality and timing,
then you could use portfolio volatility
and correlation modeling
to sort of make what is likely the best
decision at the portfolio level.
So, for example, let's say as well as TPX,
we're also considering universal display
core.
So OLED.
And ultimately, you think that there's
nothing between these two ideas in terms
of quality or conviction.
One approach to consider is modeling how
the portfolio structure is affected
with including each one and then making a
decision based on that.
So let's remove TPX now and include OLED
instead to see how things change.
So you can see here that the estimated
portfolio volatility has decreased as has
the average correlation
inside the portfolio and OLED itself looks
to be less correlated in each pairwise
relationship.
Now, I wouldn't say there's a massive
amount in it, but it is something.
OLED looks slightly more attractive at the
portfolio level in this case.
However, that is only the risk side of
things.
Perhaps we should also be expecting lower
returns from OLED.
Well, if what I said before is true and
everything about this trade really is on
equal terms,
then that should have already been
considered before we even got to this
point.
But if we wanted to go back and check the
historical and implied volatility of the
stock at this point
and think about whether that changes our
expectations, we could do that as well.
So those are the sorts of things that you
should be thinking about in terms of
modeling portfolio volatility and
correlations,
thinking about what your portfolio
structure looks like when you add
positions or change positions.
And as I've been saying throughout this
video and the last video, not every bit of
analysis that we're looking at here is
actionable in and of itself.
It should be noted and considered in the
broad context of everything else.
And once you've completed the whole course
and started down the road of practical
implementation yourself,
you'll be in a far more informed and
confident mind frame in making some of
these decisions.
So that's it. There's nothing else to look
at in this video.
The rest of the spreadsheet is all the
same.
Please remember all of the practical
implementation steps from the last video,
though, because they do apply again here.
And what I mean by that is how you update
and prepare all of your prices and returns
data so that it feeds through correctly to
the portfolio volatility and correlation
models.
OK, so what are the important points to
take away from this video and the last one
in terms of correlation and portfolio
structuring?
In the last video, we learned that a
portfolio's variance is a function of both
the variances and covariances of
individual assets within the portfolio.
However, we found that as more assets are
added to the portfolio,
it's the covariance terms that become the
dominant contributors to the eventual
output of portfolio volatility.
We learned that the relationship between
assets then, whether measured in terms of
covariance or correlation,
is the most important factor in portfolio
diversification.
With that in mind then, it set us up with
the key concept running throughout this
video,
which has been that correlation assessment
is a hugely important factor to consider
in the context of portfolio construction.
And I've talked through and demonstrated
that in a number of ways.
We've discussed how efficient
diversification leads to higher risk
adjusted returns.
What I mean by efficient diversification
is incorporating positions in the
portfolio with low correlations to reduce
portfolio risk at a faster rate and a
higher magnitude than if we included
medium or high correlation positions.
That allows us to sufficiently diversify
without including so many positions that
we then sacrifice the quality and
conviction of our ideas,
which is obviously detrimental to our
expected returns.
Remember also that the more positions you
add, the lower the marginal benefit of
risk reduction becomes anyway.
So building a long short portfolio that
predominantly incorporates mid cap stocks
is a great vehicle to actually achieve
this.
A mix of long and short trades is a
massive aid to lower correlation positions
and hence reduce risk.
And mid caps not only offer up the
opportunity for higher profits than larger
cap stocks,
but also give us a wider range of
correlations to work with.
And often they'll represent a more
efficient diversifier than their larger
cap counterparts as well.
So with that being said, there's a few
things to consider at this point from a
practical perspective.
There are many considerations in using
correlation values as I covered throughout
the first section of this video.
And it would be naive to assume that
historical correlation always implies
future correlation,
since there may be events in the future
that cause correlations to change, even if
only temporarily.
So we've seen that in a number of examples
throughout the video.
One of the most important ones being when
we looked at what happens when liquidity
crises occur and correlations tend to one.
There's a sort of dash for cash and all
assets tend to move in the same direction.
So correlations tend to one.
I've already touched on the idea of over
diversification as well,
but that is another important practical
consideration.
Because even in the unrealistic scenario
where we assume we can find an endless
number of low correlation ideas to add to
the portfolio,
we still need to be cognizant of the
opportunity or profit side of the
equation.
And what I mean by that is that over
diversification tends to lead to executing
lower quality and lower conviction ideas,
and that can seriously damage future
returns.
So there still needs to be a certain
amount of concentration of positions to
maximize returns whilst taking advantage
of low correlations where possible.
And for the umpteenth time, correlation
considerations always come after solid
fundamental analysis.
Another thing I want to reiterate from the
previous video is that by constructing a
long short portfolio,
we've seen that estimated portfolio
volatility decreases significantly.
Despite the reduction in volatility,
it's important to remember that that
doesn't necessarily mean less opportunity
for profit.
Long short portfolio strategies can work
in all markets,
which actually is much better for wealth
creation over time.
And we talked about that in the previous
video.
But not only that, as I've said before,
the diversification benefits are much more
efficient due to the low or negatively
correlated positions,
which means our risk adjusted returns can
be much greater.
We can also increase upside in our returns
or the opportunity side of the equation by
structuring our trades with leveraged
products such as options,
which is something we talk about in the
Professional Options Trading Masterclass
video series.
Not only does that allow for magnified
returns,
but if it's used correctly, it can also be
a really great way of managing risk as
well due to their asymmetric risk
profiles.
All of those concepts and the theory that
we've talked about hopefully came together
when we went through some examples and
scenarios
where I practically demonstrated how you
could use the portfolio volatility and
correlation spreadsheet models that I've
built for you for your own purposes.
Using that spreadsheet is something that
you should be doing on a pretty regular
basis to help yourselves understand your
own portfolios,
where the risks lie and also make
decisions based on your current and
prospective portfolio structures.
Always remember though, with all of that
in context, to successfully implement
correlation analysis,
you need to understand how correlation
works and its pitfalls so that you don't
rely too much on a single statistical
number
and become sort of complacent about
correlation analysis.
Because, you know, correlation analysis,
like everything else, is just a tool to
improve the probability of success.
And it's by no means the holy grail.
Anyway, good work guys.
This volatility and correlation stuff
isn't that easy to get your head around,
but I'm sure you'll all get the hang of it
as you watch and re-watch these videos and
also play around with all the spreadsheets
and practically implement what you've
learned as well.
That's it for this video though.
And I'll see you in the next one where
we're going to talk about portfolio beta,
how you can measure it and why it's
useful.